so our first question is from kate
schrader at access hollywood
hi
congratulations this was an amazing
series you guys are both so well
deserved but evan i got to say that
impassioned kate winslet squeal are you
guys celebrating together tonight
yeah
she she's just phenomenal we were just
saying on the way over here that i would
just give this to her because she's just
so incredible and uh
i don't know i i definitely would be
here if it wasn't for her the best scene
partner i could have ever asked for an
amazing human being and uh so down to
earth and i i just love her she's
awesome
thank you so much kate congratulations
and next up liz trinier from ctv etalk
hey liz
hey congratulations i mean i was so
in love with your show and just enamored
every single episode on the edge of my
seat congratulations um so how does
winning an emmy compare to working with
kate winslet
i'll i'll take the work with kate any
day this um we got to know her really
well as evan said she took such good
care of all of us
and i know we all learned from her every
day
and that's more valuable i would say
that's true she's incredibly
detail-oriented and brilliant and uh
like i said an amazing human being so
just just learning all around but we're
happy about these two yeah we like these
as well so let's get both yay
congratulations you earned it thank you
thank you thank you now we have rhymah
with women's wear daily congratulations
to you both
wildly well deserved such a fan of the
series i'd love to know we're all at
home what is it like
inside the room tonight what is the mood
the ambiance
i think the mood is really joyful and
celebratory and upbeat and people feel
like they're all there to just support
each other and cheer each other on so
cedric's doing a great job that opening
song was a total surprise seth rogen i'm
having a blast yeah what about you
absolutely the opening segment was
amazing and i think everybody's just
happy to be back in the company of other
people it's really really kind of nice
thank you rima
and we now have one last question from
tonya hart at american urban radio
networks hi how are you guys
congratulations
and someone just took my question i was
going to say what was it like in the
room and but i'll ask you this one so
cedric has changed clothes several times
have you noticed how he does this
um it's like magic i think that he's
like cloned himself and there's a few of
him roaming around the building just
like getting ready for his next segment
exactly so what would you say is the
best part of not so much winning of
winning the emmy tonight but really just
doing the show when you're on the set
what makes you feel good at the end of
the day
oh gosh i i you know this is this is uh
i found this show to be very challenging
it's very difficult material
you obviously had so much difficult
stuff to do uh everyone ever literally
everyone and i i think at the end of the
day when you go home if you feel good
about
that and and and working with you know
craig's oval our director and kate and
and everybody if you just feel good
about that that's that's good that's a
huge win
yeah i would say so too and also just
the response to the show the way people
seem to have
fallen for it so deeply has been
incredibly moving to me i've never
experienced anything like it and that's
been insane um
very gratifying
[Music]
you